welcome to the Dave Ramsey show America
we're glad you're with us in the lobby
of financial peace Plaza right here in
the edge of Martha's place they're here
Spencer antenna our Tanya are here what
are you tenure or are you Tanya tani is
fine Tanya yeah welcome guys good to
have you howdy here so where are you
from Chattanooga Tennessee Oh fine
welcome to Nashville and I'm guessing
you're here to do your debt-free scream
yes sir all right very cool good for you
guys how much debt have you paid off
we paid off $40,000 and nine and a half
months forty thousand bucks and nine and
a half months making what kind of money
we started off making eighty five
thousand dollars a year and then we're
now up to a hundred thousand what go the
really cool thing that I wanted to tell
you about was when I came to the company
that I'd drive truck for now I was on my
way to lease a semi that I would have
put four thousand dollars down and I
would have paid $400 a week for the next
four years but thanks to one of the
shows that you did I held off I drive
for another owner operator right now
last month we bought our own truck cash
and we'll have it on the road come
January and that'll represent about a 40
percent pay increase for us with no
payments anymore very well done very
cool antenna what do you do I'm a house
manager for an agency who support and we
do residential care for individuals with
intellectual and physical disabilities
Wow considered a house manager I live in
and take care of for ladies oh wow while
he's on the road right yes okay usually
home every night I stay right around the
Nashville Knoxville Atlanta area mm-hmm
but because we wanted to get it done in
the nine and a half months there was a
lot of times that I slept out in the
truck sometimes I would drive by the
house 30 minutes down the road and sleep
in the truck just so I had a head start
for the next day that was hard yeah bad
I mean being it's one thing when you're
in Denver and you know that you can't
get home
when you pass the house and kind of wave
and give a little nod and keep going
what kind of debt was this we started
off with we had two car loans one of
them we got rid of the sport track we
owed 15 on it we only sold it for ten
five so we had to come out of pocket for
the change on that but that took care of
about ten thousand dollars of the forty
thousand and then I had my student loan
from truck driving school to get that
behind us and then we also had one of
those free dog stories that you talked
about that cost us four thousand dollars
you got a free dog not anymore we had to
pay the four thousand dollars for the
dog and in the house that we transfer to
didn't allowed that type of dog so we
had to let her go so but the four
thousand dollars stayed with us yeah
until we got it paid off the dog left
and the bill stayed so what happened
nine and a half months ago Tanya where
you guys decided to get out of death
tired of living paycheck to paycheck and
I hate spending money because I lived in
fear of something happening and I
wouldn't I wouldn't even want to pay
bills because I was I you know a lot of
people think because I didn't like to
spend money that was a great quality in
me and it wasn't because it was all fear
base mmm and I was just tired of being
miserable and fighting and about money
everything always comes back to money
you know I know how long you guys been
married 30 years so whose idea was this
nine and a half months ago to start this
hardcore plan his I had a run from
Chattanooga to Tullahoma every day and
as soon as I got over top of the rock I
could tune in and hear your station huh
I was actually to be honest with you
waiting for the guy that came on after
you I ended up getting really attached
it was actually kind of the Pink Floyd
going out music that caught my attention
off the bat but as I listened to you
more I found myself I'm driving down the
road in my semi crying like a little
schoolgirl right everybody else is kind
of looking at me and I'm like they're
dead free come on man don't you get it
they're dead
really dude they really did motivate me
I was a type of person if you gave me
$20 I'd figure out how to spend 30 okay
and she was usually where I got the
other $10 from I'd like you know pry it
out of her fist event which we headed to
her fear yes yes sir
and so it got me thinking about being
debt-free and that never motivated me
before because I can always make more
money tomorrow but I got to thinking
about it and then I thought well why do
you want to be debt-free and I realized
that it was for respect but it wasn't
for other people's respect I realized
that I had stopped seeing respect in her
eyes for me and I wanted that back and
so that became my driving force to where
when I passed the house even though I
may not be coming home tonight I'm doing
this because I'm trying to get something
back and then I realized something even
more that when I looked in the mirror I
didn't see respect in my own eyes either
and that's the biggest gift that your
curriculum has given to me is when I
look in those eyes and I look in my own
eyes I see respect and I like that a man
and that's why I'm never going back
amen it's too it's too beautiful a thing
to lose amen I think you just got a
whole lot of respect in other people's
eyes to just now that's a great story I
like that that's touching that's
powerful and there is something that
happens I know when Sharon and I went
broke and lost everything I had that
same situation got the crap beat out I
mean I didn't feel like I was worthy and
and and she thought I was stupid because
I was tell her all the time would you
just relax and I didn't realize that I
was the thing keeping her from being
able to relax yeah since we have since
we have paid off our last bill I've
gotten my high school sweetheart back I
mean it's like honeymoon all over yeah
that's awesome man you're a real man
it's like that I like you dude you're
awesome that's absolutely incredible
Tanya is that all right does that feel
right to you that's wonderful
I can't even I wish that we would have
done this years ago
and my kids would have grown up with two
different parents you know and I'm just
glad that's now
and and I think our kids mostly they see
it they see the difference yeah well
there's got to be inspired by this story
if they're not there's something wrong
with their hearts it's a great story you
guys are awesome
well very fun what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is just
discipline is wonderful I mean it sounds
terrible but discipline mm-hmm
brings freedom for me it's about a dream
it's about having something out there
that you can focus on like for me when I
spend all the hours that I spend on the
dashboard driving down the road but it's
just it's constantly thinking about it
was the driving force of getting my own
truck and getting it on the road and now
that that's come to fruition it's
constantly finding something else right
now we have a 1990 Harley Davidson and
next years our 30 year anniversary and
we've decided that plan 3 see I've never
heard you mention that but I'm adding a
3 C is we are looking at a 2008 Harley
Davidson and a trip down to Key West
Florida there you go so keeping stuff
like that that like makes gives you the
why and each day when you want to go
home you know there were times that I
would pull into the yard where we parked
the trucks and some of the other guys
would be headed home and I was just
hooking up to another trailer for my
second trip down to Atlanta and that can
be disheartening but when you have a
goal and your goal becomes stronger than
the daily desire I've heard you say it a
hundred times when your goal becomes
stronger than your desire to either go
home and sit on the couch or whatever
else that gives you something to take
that moment and do with it everything
you can to reach your goals there you go
man that's awesome well done
well done I love it well we can call
this plan 3 HD there we go baby step 3
HD well done dude well done you guys
that's a wonderful story Spencer and
Tanya from Chattanooga Tennessee $40,000
paid off in nine and
five months got his own truck hitting
the road in January paid for no payments
no leases no nervin
$85,000 to a hundred thousand oh it's
gonna go up from there
count it down let's hear a great debt
free scream now and forevermore
we
awesome fair that's so fun
very well done you guys very well done
love it love it love it respect yeah
that's a good one right there I don't
motivate you but love it wow this is the
Dave Ramsey show
you